gold silver keys golden keys Ruby Keys
clock turnkeys echocrystal Jewels gems
thank you notes past Point straight
tokens Club Points Club coupons and
leprechaun gold honestly I wouldn't be
surprised if I still miss some look
Harry Potter magic awakened has so many
different currencies to understand don't
worry though today we're going to break
down every single one of them and this
is gonna be incredibly valuable
information whether you plan to spend
real world money on the game or stay as
a free-to-play player get out your ink
and quills feel free to take notes
rewind watch part of the video again
because I admit there is a lot to this
so we'll start with gold which in my
opinion is the most important currency
in Harry Potter magic awakened it has a
pretty straightforward description a
shiny currency that can be used to
upgrade cards and purchase items the
first item there is incredibly important
in order to progress and take on tougher
challenges and Magic awakened you'll
need to upgrade your cards which in turn
ups the overall power of your Spellbook
you also need multiple copies of the
same card in order to upgrade it and of
course the higher you go in upgrading
the card the more gold it will require
Fortune you can get gold from a lot of
different places in the game including
the magic pass Forbidden Forest
including the Ford Anglia daily tasks
and dueling and a quick note on the
magic pass that does include the free
version of the magic pass as well so the
top row of the pass all players have
access to that you can also use gold to
buy a variety of items in the daily shop
including a legendary card for 20 000
gold probably not worth it unless you
somehow have a ton of gold lying around
mostly because you want to be really
careful with how you spend your gold it
is going to take so much gold to level
up your cards I strongly advise you guys
to Choose Wisely which cards you decide
to upgrade Focus mainly on upgrading the
cards that you enjoy using in your
Forbidden Forest runs or dueling because
that's where it's really important to
have higher level cards the UI of the
game almost encourages you to fully
upgrade every card you can but again I
do not recommend that make sure you have
a good understanding of the game and
which cards play well with the Echoes
you have the Echoes are basically like a
special ability for your entire deck and
speaking of Echoes let's talk about
another currency Echo crystals this is
one area where the game really does not
do a great job at explaining the best
way to upgrade your Echoes the
description for Echo Crystal simply says
that they are brilliant crystals that
increase the effects of your Echoes
they're obtained from The Forbidden
Forest or Echo conversion now you may
think the primary purpose of these
crystals is to use them to upgrade your
Echoes after all if you go to the menu
here to upgrade you can see the game
will automatically have them selected
and even have it set to fully upgrade
the echo if you have enough crystals
that is but this is actually not the
best way to upgrade them and nowhere
close to being the most cost efficient
so you know all of those lower tiered
Echoes that you keep getting from the
forest what's the point right well by
unchecking the echo Crystal option right
down here you can then check the gray
Circle which by the way first I didn't
know what these circles were these
circles actually represent the different
Echoes that you currently have and the
Rarity of them so let's say I check the
gray and blue circles here that is going
to allow me to upgrade my Echoes using
just lower tier echoes in the rare and
common category yes it still requires
gold but you save those crystals if
you're early in the game it may not seem
like it now but there will come a time
when you have so many Echoes and you
really want to pick and choose which
ones you upgrade the ones that you do
should mostly be based on the cards that
they can boost you see in addition to
the standard ability of each Echo they
will also boost different cards in the
game and this is totally random you
should really only put upgrade resources
Into The Echoes that have cards you want
to use in your deck so then where to use
the echo crystals the crystals can
actually be used to change one of the
boosted cards again though it's all up
to RNG which card you get and on top of
that the cost of changing one of those
boosted cards it increases each time you
do it oh and the price jumps even more
if you want to change more than one of
the boosted cards so yeah lots and lots
of echo crystals will be required if you
want to change these out this is why
it's so important to focus on upgrading
The Echoes that already have at least a
few cards you like and don't waste your
resources on ones that don't so you can
really think of the echo crystals as the
currency that can take some of your
favorite Echoes and make them just a
little bit better by giving you a
different boosted card all right now how
about we talk about the cards how do you
get more of them this is where Keys come
into play we'll start with silver keys
which Grant one basic study attempt you
can get these from the magic pass daily
tasks Forbidden Forest and dueling Club
there's also an option to purchase them
with gems but it's probably not the best
value you'll find the basic study option
each day in the shop under the magical
study section one silver key will give
you two random cards of the Epic Rarity
or lower and you're guaranteed to get an
epic card at least every 30 draws the
game even keeps track of it for you
right here on the right we have the
advanced study section and this is where
you can spend your golden keys now with
the golden keys you have a chance for
Mythic legendary and dark cards you're
guaranteed one of those every 20 draws
you get these in the same way as silver
keys but of course they're harder to get
because they yield better rewards keys
can also be spent one at a time or
stacked to spend multiple keys at once
and from what I can tell there's really
no reason to save silver or gold keys
unlike gold you can pretty much use
these Keys as soon as you get them to
get better cards now I should also add
another way to get keys is through
various quests reaching certain
milestones and also making sure you keep
an eye out for limited time events where
keys can show up as rewards not so fast
though there's also Ruby keys and these
Ruby keys are tied to special events at
the time of recording this video they
can be used in the season exclusive
gluttony whelp event as well as the
special enrollment deal event you can
only get Ruby keys by buying them with
gems or getting them through special
events there's one currently ongoing
where you can progress the yearbook
stories to claim up to 30 Ruby Keys
what's unique about Ruby Keys is the
events will have a special weight for a
certain card for example right now the
enrollment deal card pool gives you a
higher chance at the Mythic Ron Weasley
card whereas the season limited event
gives you higher odds of the baby
antibody and opal eye card oh and I
almost forgot clock turnkeys these keys
are used to take a spin of the mystery
wheel now I got two free keys to start
from some special event thing I think
everyone gets that but then after that
you'll have to buy more of them with
gems the mystery wheel items contain a
few standard items like silver keys
golden keys but also rare items like
special clothing a snowy owlette a wand
skin and a Decor dream box and we've
mentioned gems a few times already here
so let's go ahead and break that one
down even further gems are described as
a precious currency that can be used to
purchase rare items and services they
are obtained through the magic pass
daily tasks solo exploration and dueling
Club you can also buy these using
another currency that requires real
world money but we'll get to that one in
a second gyms actually pop up quite a
bit in various bundles in the shop they
can also be used to buy other currencies
such as gold or Keys now we've covered
quite a few currencies so far but we've
yet to talk about real world money after
all this game is free to play and does
rely on micro transactions to make a
profit that is where Jewels come in
Jewels are a pinkish purple gem only
obtainable with real world money they
can be used to buy booster packs
containing keys and gold or you can use
them to purchase gems outright alright
we are in the home stretch now I promise
guys let's go rap rapid fire here and
knock out a few of the easy to
understand currencies we have pass
points which are earned by completing
daily tasks and leveling up your magic
pass Madam's coupons which can be used
to get discounts at Madame malkans and
Diagon Alley these come in two variants
first is the student coupon which grants
a 10 gym or 100 gold discount on all
items except alternate version outfits
then we have the VIP coupons which are
good for a 20 gym discount on alternate
versions of outfits both of these
coupons are obtained through the dancing
club we also have leprechaun gold that's
only used in The Forbidden Forest and
this gold does not carry over to Future
runs so this is definitely one that you
want to just spend each time that you
come across that Merchant and you're
going through your Forester run use that
leprechaun gold and level up what you
prefer if you're part of a social club
and I highly recommend you join one
because there are so many in-game
benefits but if you're part of one
you'll want to become familiar with Club
coins there are three different types of
Club coins attack skill and health these
can be used to help your whole club
during the club Adventures you'll have
to work together as a group to progress
and unlock each of these upgrade rates
that will benefit your entire team
during the adventure next we have the
thank you notes and I would say these
are really underrated overall mostly
because you can use them at the thank
you note gift exchange to buy trade
tokens which are Super valuable again
remember how social clubs are great well
if you're part of a social club that is
also how you can request trades with
other players to get the cards you're
after to do that though you'll need
trade tokens and the token Rarity will
need to match the Rarity of the card
you're after so you need a common trade
token for the common cards rare tokens
for the rare cards and so on well guess
what one of the best ways to get those
tokens is by purchasing them with thank
you notes there is an additional way
that you can get tokens by using Club
crests and these are earned each time
you complete the club Adventure activity
so what's great about these thank you
notes is that you can grind up to 50 of
these each day and all you need to do to
get them is help others through the
Forbidden Forest you can keep grinding
these even after you've done your daily
Force runs for keys and you'll want to
try and get at least 50 in a month I
know I said you can get 50 in a day but
man that's a lot of game time just make
sure you at least 50 in a month though
so that you can buy the legendary trade
token this token enables you to make a
legendary trade but you can only buy one
of those trade tokens each month but
then of course that also requires you
having an extra legendary card that
you're willing to create someone else so
how exactly does trading work well I
think that requires another video in
fact I've already made one for you it's
here on the right side of your screen
now check that one out next guys let me
know if you have any other questions
about the currency and as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon